hi I'm Erik Bosse and it's here guys
Game of Thrones season 7 trailer our
first look at the new season HBO is
calling this trailer the Great War and
it has everything we love about battles
cavalry charges cities being sacked
pirate big map now there is so much in
this trailer and I'm going to break it
all down frame by frame everything you
might have missed with some theories and
predictions for what we'll see over
these seven episodes so let's get
started enemies to be used to the West
[Music]
enemies to the south enemies to the move
okay so the opening shots shows Cersei
in the red cape and right away there's
something interesting here Cersei looks
like she's wearing fur King's Landing
remember is normally pretty warm so the
fact that it's already sweater weather
this far south suggests that she also
must be feeling that winter is here
along with the threats at winter brains
now this first section of the trailer
features Cersei listing or enemies
closing in on her from all directions of
the map east with grey worm and the
unsullied invading from Essos west
beyond in Yara's Greyjoy's ship from the
iron islands south what looks like one
of the sand snakes from Dorne sharpening
a knife or a spear and North the little
ninja north of the neck Arya by the way
it's interesting that the editing makes
it so that the northern threat isn't you
know talking in the door for even
scarier the White Walkers but I guess
that while those may be bigger threats
neither of them hate thirsty as much as
Arya does so in a way that kind of makes
their deadlier now each of these threats
and directions play over shots of the
stone map table at Dragonstone now very
similar to the opening title sequence of
every Game of Thrones episode the camera
soars over this starting at King's
Landing following the Kings Road north
past juice Cadell along the Blackwater
Bay then through the Vale of Arryn then
to the wall and this is interesting
because this battle map is actually
being shown not from the point of view
of the Queen who's currently plotting
her defenses but from the Queen trying
to unseat her Daenerys this table was
built by Daenerys his ancestor Aegon the
Conqueror who conquered Westeros
on the back of his three dragons and
that exact history is something that
Daenerys is planning to repeat and
another thing check out how the angle of
this shot on the table frames the
fireplace in the background with the top
where the wall is on the mat now a few
shots in a trailer later hints at a huge
battle sequence at set in the north
probably later on in the season and in
this shot making the wall look like it's
on fire
could be foreshadowing that battle and
before I move on the music of Game of
Thrones is always awesome composed or
Ramin Djawadi is really at the top of
their game and in this opening section
he uses mostly strings violins but also
upright double date and if you listen
carefully with the perfect pitch that we
all have that super low bass note there
is a C which is the lowest possible
pitch of any stringed instrument like
normally the low note on a basic tuned
to an E but if you release that string
and make it looser it can extend lower
to AC this up here is called an
extension which allows the bass to go
down to a low C so why does jarate do
this well for one this is a super low
note and it definitely produces a sense
of dread which is totally what Circe is
feeling as their enemies close in on her
but also extending this low E to an even
lower
rock bottom C suggests that as bad as
things are for Circe right now it's
still possible for things to descend to
an even worse place for her and all the
characters when this great war really
begins alright let's move on
who's doomed no way we will defeat
with anarchist
okay so in this section we see that like
Daenerys Queen Cersei has a big map of
her own she's converted the red keep
courtyard into the big format like that
Carmen Sandiego game show now notice
where Cersei is standing here she's
standing on the twin that's the location
of the Lannisters largest victory the
murder of rod stark at the red wedding
which ended the war the five kings but
that area is also called the neck of
Westeros as if Cersei is stomping on the
neck of the Seven Kingdoms choking them
with her terrible rule meanwhile check
out Jaime here that sort of carrying is
widows wail that's Joffrey's old
Valyrian steel sword which Jaime father
Tywin created by melting down the Stark
broadsword ice into two smaller stores
now Jaime carrying the sword is
significant for a few reasons according
to george RR martin when Joffrey died
widow's wail was sent back to Casterly
Rock location actually shows up later in
Australia so maybe this means that Jaime
was at Casterly Rock for the saddle
retrieved the sword and now he's come
back to report to Cersei what happens
also remember the other Valyrian steel
sword that was forged from ice was the
one Tywin and Schley gave the Jaime
which he then gave to Brienne called
Oathkeeper so considering Jaime and
Brienne are of course the star-crossed
lovers that we all want to see end up
together
hopefully these twin Valyrian steel
swords will lead the way to this reunion
another cool way to this could go as
Jaime might use widows wail to make
another certain widow wail Cersei one of
the big theories that we brought up in
the past is the Queen Slayer theory that
Jaime's destiny is to repeat his fateful
decision to strike down the Mad King but
this time a Mad Queen so not only would
this affirm the Voland Cara prophecy
from the book where the wood which
warned Cersei that she would die at the
hands of her younger brother this would
be some nice poetic justice here with
Cersei dying from the same Valyrian
steel of the stark family that she
screwed over so royally next as the
Lannister army marches in the battle
which looks awesome by the way we never
seen their armor looks so vivid we get
this shot of Cersei on the Iron Throne
and notice how she's replaced the
seven-pointed star with her Lannister
lion
did away with the state religion by new
key and deceptive baler at the end of
last season so it makes sense that she
would
move any religious iconography and make
things all about her now also who is
talking to Cersei in this shot it looks
like some man with short hair and
judging from Percy's disgusted look here
I'm thinking it could be you're on
Greyjoy and the reason I think that is
that you're in storyline in the show
seems to be following the character of
his brother Victarion Greyjoy who's only
in a book and part of that characters
journey is to pledged to make an
alliance through marriage and that could
be what you're on it's doing here with
Cersei maybe offering to get my big
talks now whether or not it goes that
way I'm guessing no you're on would
still be the only potential ally that
Cersei has left and hid sleet could be
the only thing that protects her from
the massive Navy that Daenerys is
bringing her way now when Cersei implies
that Tyrion is a Lannister who doesn't
count we cut to Tyrion with the three
dragons on Dragonstone and I'm guessing
that Cersei underestimated Tyrion is
definitely going to blow up in her face
somehow also notice how the sounds of
the troops marching from the lancer trip
earlier continue through this shot as we
move on to Tyrion on Dragonstone the
sound editing suggests that all these
characters are in their own way marching
to war alright let's move on
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
[Music]
and I will
okay so here we see Daenerys his
long-awaited homecoming to her
birthplace of Dragonstone the gates open
up and she sees her Targaryen family
sigil the dragon on the window of the
castle of us how so like how this shot
focuses on her touching the shore kind
of like a warrior coming home from war
and kissing the ground this moment is
Danny's first contact with Westeros
these soils and she was a newborn also
notice how the music and the section
changes there's heavier percussion and
if you listen closely it sounds like a
voice is whispering the three syllables
of Khaleesi
[Music]
it's almost as this as Dany returns to
her ancestral home on her way the Iron
Throne she's remembering her past
leadership roles one of them being
Khaleesi that led her to this point next
up is one of the most interesting parts
of this trailer the unsullied sacking a
city with Lannister banners and yeah
that's probably either Casterly Rock
or the larger port city that it
overlooks Lannisport that banner kind of
looks like it's in an L shape so this is
a big deal this is the ancestral home of
the Lannister family and we've never
seen it on the show before like Casterly
Rock has always been talked about but
it's always been considered untouchable
remember Robb Stark planned to attack it
right after the red wedding but
obviously he never got that chance but
now that Cersei has made enemies out of
everyone in Westeros
her Lannister army has probably spread
thin across the countryside defending
her rule which could have left her home
city undefended and now it looked like
Daenerys can deliver on Robb Stark's old
plan deploying the unsullied to strike
right at the Lannisters heart by taking
their home also this would have even
wider implications remember the source
of the Lannisters power is their
reputation as the wealthiest family in
Westeros the Lannisters always pay their
debt but in the past Tywin revealed that
the family is secretly broke the gold
mines of Casterly Rock have all run dry
years ago and now that an outside force
is sacking the city that secret could
become public knowledge
causing Lannister stock to plummet doing
further damage to sir seized power and
reputation all right let's move on
just--how that brothers are gone yet
here you stand
that best hope against the coming storm
if we don't put aside our enmities and
band together we will die okay so this
next section takes us to the north as in
Victor you know
and joining John and Winterfell look
closely is Brienne who apparently made
it back safely from Riverrun and in this
wide shot of the halt of Winterfell you
can see little finger on the side along
with tormund the wildly in sitting among
the northern houses also there's one
northerner who looks a lot like two pro
wrestler Eric Rowan
like Lou gamble still sounds fun and now
we got someone who can tag in but then
we get this moment between Littlefinger
and Sansa and just like he did at the
end of last season Littlefinger is still
trying to empower Sansa over jon like
nothing in Sansa but I would still say
jon is the last best hope against the
coming storm
clearly Littlefinger is just trying to
worm his way into influenced by his
setting the power structure in Blair
fell and later in the section there's a
mysterious shot of little fingers dimly
lit face either in the Winterfell crypts
or maybe in a dungeon so it's possible
that little fingers Medellin could land
up in trouble in Winterfell and then
after this icy shot of the northern
gates of Castle black opening up we cut
to fire jump cut of ice and fire if you
will to see on surrounded by flames
maybe as the ship burns around him I had
more thoughts on this later but we also
see Melisandre at Dragonstone now it
makes sense that she would return to
this place after Sir Devoe's banished
her from Winterfell a the last season
this is where she first came into the
picture making sacrifices on beach of
the red guy and birthing Brother killing
smoked babies but mostly at who she's
gazing down at walking along the narrow
pathway that looks like Tyrion down
there along with a figure wearing a big
cloak and I'm guessing that's Jon
there's been a ton of leech set photos
that have hinted that Jon will appear at
Dragonstone so this could be confirming
that but also based on this plea for
unity that we hear from sir Davos it
sounds like they're both on a diplomatic
mission to Daenerys trying to get her to
join forces with them to take on the
White Walkers
remember Dragonstone is also rumored to
contain large quantities of dragonglass
one of the few known weaknesses of the
White Walkers so that could be part of
their mission as well but my prediction
is that this whole meeting will be set
up by Melisandre who left things in a
pretty bad place to sir Davos and Jon
and it's probably looking for a way to
redeem ourselves there all
so two quick shots here of wild lanes or
maybe northerners or Rangers dressed up
in Wyoming furs running and then
circling up defensively in a blizzard
really closely one of these guys is
holding a Warhammer so yeah they're
probably facing off against White
Walkers suggesting that these shots are
either part of an excursion that people
are making north of the wall or this is
part of a big battle scene that's
supposed to take place of the wall
rumored to come later in the season okay
let's move on and then it doesn't matter
whose skeleton sits on the Iron Throne
[Music]
okay this section shows us more battle
shot with the cavalry charge by the
Dothraki bloodrider now notice how they
synchronize when they rise and perch on
their horses preparing to leap off at
the same time I'm really excited to see
how well choreographed this whole pitch
battle is now where is this battlefield
exactly my prediction is that Daenerys
is going to divide her forces that we
saw with her at the end of season six
like we saw her send the unsullied to
attack Casterly Rock which is on the
west coast of Westeros and then I think
that these Dothraki are invading
Westeros from the heath in the crown
lands near King's Landing meanwhile I
think there's a third branch to Daenerys
forces her Navy commanded by Yara and
Beyond joined by the ships that we saw
from the Martel's from Dorne and the
Tyrells from Highgarden and I predict
this Navy is what will face off with the
massive fleet of euron greyjoy
which is what we're seeing in this fiery
ship battle if you look closely Raiders
from one ship are boarding the one
that's on fire and one of these guys is
carrying a shield with Joran vigil and I
think this is the same fiery place that
we saw Theon in that earlier shot it's
looking like this battle with his uncle
isn't going too well for him and then
check out this line from sir Davos never
just matter who skeleton ships on behind
for now based on the lighting on his
face and the words that he's picking
this seems like something he's saying to
Daenerys in the dragon stones throne
room now the image of a skeleton on the
Iron Throne well it's super spooky for
one but it also connects to Daenerys his
vision back in season two when the red
cape was destroyed and covered in snow
an apocalyptic future where no one wins
the game of Thrones so hopefully Davos
is scare tactics here will remind an
heiress of this memory and the overall
big picture we also get this quick shot
of the mountains now where a new black
Kingsguard armor now ever since
Cersei resurrected him and stole the
throne and one swift move to become an
evil Emperor I feel like her
relationship with a mountain is very
parallel with the Emperor and Darth
Vader in Star Wars and yeah this new
shiny black helmet and armor definitely
completes that picture now there are two
quick shots in the Winterfell crypts
where Jon seems to shove little finger
against the wall it actually kind of
reminds me of the way Ned Shub little
finger against the wall in season one
now this is interesting because one of
the big questions after season six was
now that we
so that jon snow's parents are actually
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen how
will john find this out and what will
happen when he does and one possible
answer that i brought up before is
Littlefinger remember back in season
five there was a scene with Littlefinger
and Sansa in this same spot in the
Winterfell crypts at the grave of Lyanna
stark and when Sansa said that Rhaegar
kidnapped and raped Lee and a little
finger went silent and gave this
interesting expression cuz if he knew
more to the story so it's possible that
Littlefinger is one of these few people
in Westeros who knows the truth about
Jon's parentage now sure he wasn't there
at the Tower of joy but Littlefinger was
there at the tourney of Harrenhal which
is where Rhaegar first made a move on
Liana handing her a blue rose instead of
his wife Elia Martell who scandal and
maybe through his network of informants
Littlefinger learned that Liana and Rhea
guards love was actually consensual and
when Ned Stark returned to Winterfell
with a baby Littlefinger was able to put
two two together I always knew the
Honorable Lord Stark
never father a bastard so who maybe
Jon's outburst here is a reaction to
Littlefinger telling him the truth like
either he thinks that little fingers
lines
there's no Targaryen blood and maizing
or he's mad at Littlefinger for not
telling him sooner or he feels
threatened that Littlefinger might use
this information against him somehow
like if Jon isn't the son of Ned Stark
rather his sister Lyanna that might kind
of weaken his claim to the Lord of
Winterfell and possibly dr. John or like
technically Sansa has a stronger claim
or brand once people find out he's still
alive or maybe none of this legitimacy
stuff matters like the guy did come back
from the dead and win the battle of the
bacter it's a pretty strong claim and
before I move on to this final section
there's a quick shot of a crippled hand
reaching out through a door now at first
this opening looks like the one leading
to the dungeon room that Cersei left
septa unella in at the end of last
season but then look at these wounds on
the arm that looks a lot like greyscale
so I'm guessing that this is actually
Sir Jorah Mormont
with his greyscale getting way worse and
maybe now he's forced into this
quarantine
dungeon okay let's move on to this last
part
[Music]
the Great Wall is here Wow okay lots of
big stuff here so let's break it all
down first we're back at this Dothraki
charged with a blood Ryder swinging his
Arak and that is a Lannister soldier
there so this huge pitch battle that
we've been seeing shots of will be a
showdown between the forces of Daenerys
and Cersei and I'm so pumped for this
epic clash of Queen also pretty pumped
for this clash between these two Yara
and ilaria but they're not the only ones
who are getting any action there's also
this shot of grey worm and Musante
getting some too and then there's this
look of John and tormund running for
dear life with John and Wilding fer
suggesting that he was one of those guys
in those earlier shots and this is all
part of the same big sequence we also
see Daenerys using a piece from her map
table to knock over the Lannister lion
like a chess piece and this shot reminds
me of the way that Catelyn and Rob moved
pieces around on their war board as they
planned their assault on Casterly Rock
again I think this callback is
intentional and Daenerys intends to
deliver on that same goal and then after
we see these two figures fall in the
water it's taking what looks like dragon
fire we hear the roar of a dragon and
the most epic shot of this trailer rogue
on grown to the size of a freaking 747
soaring over the Dothraki charge and I
might just be seeing things but look
closely a dragon's head here there's a
little bump behind it and that could be
a spike or part of its tail but I think
that's Daenerys back there there was
actually promo material from the show
that showed in there it's on drug on
back if so it would be amazing to see
Daenerys lead the charge in the battle
which would actually be a callback to
the way Jon Snow opened the charge into
the epic battle from last season to
battle the bastards really I cannot wait
for the season to come back in July but
in the meantime here some lingering
questions about this trailer and what we
know about season 7 one is Daenerys
doing the right thing by attacking the
Lannisters as much as we're dying to
clear do so instead of turning her
sights north on the White Walkers like
I'm curious to see if that ambition to
reclaim the Iron Throne at all costs
will come back to haunt her in any way
and - was there any character that you
wanted to see more of in this trailer
like I know I know it's
quickly salmon Gilly like hopefully for
the seven episodes the season will just
be them talking about their baby really
I'm curious to see what
Arya's next move is like obviously she's
headed to Winterfell or home but will
she complete her revenge list and we'll
see reunite with Numair eeeh we'll see
okay that is everything I noticed in
this trailer we're going to start
talking about Game of Thrones a lot more
on this channel so keep an eye out for
more Game of Thrones theories and
breakdowns maybe some new Game of
Thrones related shows with some special
guests and let me know what you think in
the comments and if you'd like this
video please hit like and subscribe the
new rock stars you can also contribute
to us on patreon thanks so much to all
of our current patients because our
great especially Wilhelmina eveson you
can hit me up on twitter at EA vice with
any thoughts you have about Game of
Thrones or if all the new rock stars on
Twitter at new rock stars for updates on
our videos right thanks for watching bye